[Music]
let's go to ella in los angeles
california what's up ella
hi there how are we doing
um not too good to be 100 honest oh
thank you so much for being honest
what's up
um
so my husband and i have been married
for four years and he has a son from a
previous marriage and it's a really bad
um it was a bad divorce
my step since almost 10 and they're
still in a custody battle and i found
out about my husband
well we lived out of state and we moved
three years ago to be closer to
his son and that was a horrible decision
because we don't have any family but my
husband has
racked up about two hundred thousand
dollars in debt to his attorney
and he's on a payment plan of twelve
thousand dollars a month oh
all
a surprise i had no idea i
knew something was up so i went into his
email which i shouldn't have done
and i saw the bill and i
like i felt like i was going to be sick
and i told him this morning i wanted a
divorce i
mean we've just been fighting all the
time over this for the past three years
while he's been fighting for custody and
he told me that he's not going to stop
until he gets full custody and i had no
idea he was filing for full custody and
i don't want
full custody of his son because i'm a
stay-at-home mom and i would have to be
the one to
deal with him and he has some um
developmental issues i don't know if i'm
allowed to say what they are but he he
has a lot of behavioral problems and
i i'm not i can't take that on and i i
don't know what to do i just feel like
crying almost yeah first one yes that's
that's the appropriate response you're
in the middle of a hurricane right now
it's a lot
um crying is a is it
a
smart good healthy thing to do right now
um
you've got a lot that you just put out
there what can we help you with today
well
i'm
almost to the point where i want to just
you know i mean it's really hard to do
the debt snowball when he keeps i mean
this attorney is like 600 an hour some
high-profile attorney in like santa
monica
i don't know how we do the debt snowball
when he keeps adding more money and i
also don't want to pay for
this because i i feel like as a spouse
he should have come to me and said hey
i'm thinking about getting full custody
what do you think
so listen
you
we call it financial infidelity here
we call it betrayal everywhere we call
it dishonesty we call it lying whatever
words you want to call it
but your
your guts all over your kitchen floor
that feeling is correct
part of you was stolen part of your
relationship was stolen from you
and if i'm him
i don't get i don't get the betrayal
part i don't get the dishonesty part i
get the i'll go to the ends of the earth
for my son i get that but that's a
conversation you have with your wife
right especially to the tune of two
hundred thousand 000
and it just i mean it's illogical you
can't pay that
and so
your feelings are justified in good what
i don't want you doing in the midst of
this pain is making
lobbying grenades back that doesn't help
anybody
i'd love for you to get with some people
in your life that you can circle up with
and can help you walk through this piece
by piece because there's lots of pieces
this isn't the moment for baby steps
this is the moment for
your marriages i mean you you basically
told him this morning you want a divorce
and i understand why you would say that
no there's no judgment here but did you
mean it or did you just throw that out
there
um well i mean honestly these past three
years i've probably threatened divorce
honestly
it's like every other week i'm
threatening divorce so ella let's stop
that let's stop that yeah okay let's
don't threaten divorce anymore
either
i've reached the end of what i'm going
to tolerate when it comes to the
deception and getting dragged through
the mud and you living a dual life and
your dishonesty all that i'm done with
that
or i'm all in on this
but we have to be all in on this to get
like you got one or two options
threatening divorce
i mean it's just a it's a weak childish
play don't do that don't weaponize
relationships and make that but say i'm
in or i'm out and then once you say i'm
out then it becomes a business
transaction
and then we're going to go down that
road together well i
ella john's right i we certainly can
help anybody get out of debt but you
guys aren't even
we got to reconcile some huge issues
here and one is
he's not going to stop fighting for a
son at least that's his position up to
this point right so we've got to get
clear on that because you're going i
don't want to parent this kid
at the house forget the money piece yeah
the money piece is exorbitant and it's
probably going to keep growing so john's
absolutely right this is a relationship
call right now because then we decide
what do we do with the money i'm just
curious how much money does he make
well he's a real well he's in the army
reserves um and he's a real estate agent
so these last two years have been really
really good money but he's only sold one
house this month because of everything
going up so
um last year he made almost 400 thousand
dollars um and
we have nothing to show for that right
are you currently paying the twelve
thousand dollars in the uh
legal fees are you is he paying on that
or is that just racking up
um he's paying with a credit card so i
think it's just racking up oh
we have separate finances so i don't i
don't know and i'm a stay-at-home mom so
he doesn't tell me
financially i have no idea hey ella
anything ella are you safe
um
like he's not
um i'm sorry l are you safe
he's not physically abusive but it's
like he doesn't we have an age gap and
it's like he treats me like i'm his
child and um
all my family wants me to leave him
but i don't want to do that to my kids
because i promised myself i wouldn't let
my kids go through my childhood um but
it's i'm 24 and he's 49. we're almost
49. okay
so i i am never ever going to tell and
if somebody's
in the midst of um
unsafe abuse i'm gonna tell somebody get
out okay
i'm not gonna tell you to
pull the trigger here i don't know
necessarily that i agree i i think that
there's harder things going on in your
home than you're saying out loud is that
fair
yes that is okay
i want you to call somebody today
and if you've got family members who say
we love you and we're seeing something
that you're not seeing what you're
hanging on to is a picture of a fantasy
that you created because you don't want
your kids to experience what you did
which is beautiful and great and good
i'm glad you did that the reality is
your picture has changed
full stop
now the question is are you going to
hang on to that old picture and drown
and bring them with you or are you going
to create something new yeah asap and
most of us when we're drowning we cannot
get out by ourselves we need other
people and you've got people around you
saying hey we're going to help we're
going to help we're going to help please
lean on them okay and i would just say
ella you cannot fix this marriage on
your own absolutely your husband is you
can't put that glass back together on
your own
i think it's uh it's not a threat but i
think uh
i think we got to see if he wants this
marriage i i can tell you right now he
doesn't right he wants a daughter and
that's not you yeah it's time for you to
reach out to your family and y'all start
making a game plan of what comes next
and if you are being hurt get
out you're worth more